lisez ce qui suit elle aussi la
situation de près en afghanistan des
français sont toujours sur place et leur
rapatriement doit être organisé le point
justement avec notre reporter à monaco
dès lors
un conseil de défense a eu lieu au fort
de brégançon en visioconférence au côté
du président de la république florence
parly la ministre de la défense et jean
yves le drian le ministre des affaires
étrangères avec pour objectif suivre
heure par heure la situation en
afghanistan selon l'elysée la priorité
absolue c'est d'assurer la sécurité des
ressortissants français et leur retour
le plus rapidement possible mais pas
seulement le quai d'orsay a fait savoir
qu'il protégerait tous les afghans qui
avaient travaillé à leur côté toutes ces
années des interprètes des journalistes
des militants
tout sera mis en oeuvre pour qu'ils
puissent bénéficier de visas depuis
l'aéroport de kaboul entre hier et
aujourd'hui deux avions de l'armée de
l'air ont été déployés de kaboul vers
abu dhabi pour assurer le retour des
ressortissants bloqués le président de
la république s'exprimera aujourd'hui à
20 heures puisque il le sait et cette
situation aura a des conséquences et
géopolitique dramatique